favorite song to perform live okay
courage that's good
favorite song on your playlist it's not
yours too many but LP songs and CI and I
love SIA oh I love her a movie you can
watch over and over all of them whatever
my kids ones because I love them so much
they picked a movie even if I've watched
them
you're watching 65 times bigger but for
example my Monsters Inc is yes is so
great and then cheetah cheetah bang bang
and Nanny McPhee and oh I can't I can't
you pick one I show you recently benched
what is binge that you just watch the
first episode second episode third
episode 40 you just watched it all in
one setting I rarely watch TV TV but
Sheldon oh I love that show I love that
show
I'll bet your kids liked that show yes I
loved that show young Sheldon I love
that show young son favorite meal jelly
peanut butter jelly peanut butter jelly
peanut butter jelly with a baseball bat
you didn't put it on but it would be
like probably about any wish Hamas
Lebanese oh okay and describe your life
in one word Hershey
very nice birthday very nice